bientôt mon nom c'est à dire se
retrouvent aujourd'hui pour une vidéo de
prévention entre guillemets sans montage
derrière parce que ma page facebook a
été piraté
bon il ya déjà un petit mouton seulement
je sais faire bref c'est compliqué en
bref le hacker a décidé hier de mettre
en place un espèce de concours payant à
la con et en échange les gagnants auront
t shirt fin je crois que c'est quelque
chose du genre d'après ce que vous
m'avez dit voilà donc je trouve ça un
peu dommage que les gens soient plus
avoir faim ça me fait chier sincèrement
que des gens tombent dans le panneau
parce que tu n'as rien à faire de ces
journées un tout simplement
alors du coup ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est déjà ne tombait jamais dans
un panneau comme ça premièrement les
youtube heures et vous demanderont
jamais jamais jamais d'argent vous dira
jamais enfin beaucoup on est faut payer
on vous dira jamais donne moi des halles
aux bases et je te donne ça ça c'est des
trucs qu'on dira jamais c'est vraiment
impossible
les vidéos sont gratuits tout est
gratuit à rien tu es en moi par exemple
petshop cette cpi en suisse et des
tee-shirts
c'est une marque qu'on a créé avec mon
frère mais voilà en rien je vous dis à
aller acheter un tee shirt ou alors
enfin vous voyez je vous fais c'est un
service quoi c'est à côté
et jamais jamais les gens vous
demanderont de l'argent jamais youtube
augmenteront de largeur conseil numéro 2
surveiller des trucs bizarres qui se
passe sur le compte facebook twitter ou
youtube de vote tueur préféré ou de la
personne que vous aimez bien sachez que
c'est peut-être pas lui c'est simplement
peut-être un hacker qui se fait passer
pour lui qu'il usurpe son identité et
qui avec ce moyen et c'est d'avoir de
l'argent de la part des abonnés bas par
exemple en faisant comme celui qui va
avec et ma page facebook a fait en
faisant espèce de concours payant
totalement faux et débile donc voilà
c'est vraiment faites bien attention
quand c'est comme ça méfiez-vous un
septet c'est peut-être pas vraiment le
youtuber que vous avez bien qui est
derrière le conte c'est peut-être et
c'est toujours en tête fait pirater
conseil numéro 3 contre le piratage du
tout c'est de faux l'ovoïde youtuber ou
what you tube a préféré sur twitter et
sur facebook comme ça si vous êtes sûr
que s'il en est de ce fait pirater il
peut vous prévenir pour l'autre et c'est
plus rapide que de que qu'ils fassent
une vidéo ça met toujours plus de temps
à faire vidéo le plot dès que c'était en
fait un montage corps n'a été que de
tout simplement posté sur twitter si je
me suis fait piquer ma page facebook à
je ne sais pas quelle page facebook
attention c'est pas moi qui organise ce
concours un an
vous voyez donc c'est pour ça je vous
invite à mme fall au bain sur twitter et
a su calmer ma nouvelle page facebook du
coup ans parce que forcément j'ai perdu
l'ancienne c'est super les liens sont
dans la description et voilà n'hésitez
pas c'est vraiment très important pour
tout ce qui est en formation notamment
sur les applique pas aux mêmes sur les
vidéos surtout sa fin bref ce fut
bénéfique en plus sombre au stade des
bonnes grosses barres alors
malheureusement pour ceux qui sont fait
avoir par ce hacker je voulais vous
renoncez que c'est haram et je sais pas
comment faire donc si je trouve un moyen
quand vous puissiez m'envoyer une preuve
de que vous avez vraiment donner un réal
ofas etc
mais ça serait un peu compliqué bon
j'essaie de trouver ça en tout cas je
suis vraiment désolé même si je sais pas
comment il a fait c'est entre guillemets
pas de ma faute mais bon voilà ça ça me
blesse quand même que des abonnés se
passe kg comme ça et donne de l'argent
pour un bon retour du plein de ces
journées tout ça dommage donc je
m'excuse quand même auprès de vous et
puis j'espère que ça se construit un
plus jamais soyez vraiment très méfiant
à propos de ça comme je vous ai dit si
c'est des trucs bizarres vraiment
regardé sur le facebook ou sur twitter
de l'abonné plus avoir peut-être limite
si ses bonnes amies disent pas sur
twitter s'est fait pirater ou quoi c'est
vraiment très importante parce que voilà
moi ça me fait vraiment mal au coeur de
voir que les gens sont fait avoir comme
ça et ont donné d'argent à l'inconnu on
sent qu'on va écouter j'espère que
maintenant les choses sont claires la
nouvelle page facebook c'est squeeze
page officielle c'est dans la
description et mon twitter c'est x quizy
la page facebook qui s'est fait pirater
c'est x squeeze si vous arrivez à la
poire parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
arrivent pas et d'autres qui arrivent à
y accéder
n'hésitez pas à la signaler c'est très
important j'espère qu'elle sera
supprimée le plus rapidement possible en
tout cas
n'envoyez pas au 08 se sont vus machin
truc
le sms pour entre guillemets payer le
mec et pour son concours bidon voilà
c'est très important si elle est bien la
page et follow mais moi sur twitter
suivre
et puis web en tout cas j'espère que
c'est ce qu'on vous aura plu et puis je
vous dis merci à tous pour votre soutien
puisque vous avez été nombreux hier à
médéa entre guillemets essayer de dern
la page facebook
malheureusement je sais pas facebook je
pense qu'il faut voilà c'est un peu un
si bon sens n'est plus possible de la
planète donc je pense qu'ils sont pas
trop au taquet pour gérer des petits
trucs comme ça malheureusement
c'est normal d'un côté voilà en tout cas
j'espère que vous serez nombreux à
rejoindre sur twitter et sur facebook et
je vous dis à bientôt
pis et bonnes vacances a profité bien
m